hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video witschel zettler eingeblendet
whatsapp frank lukas rieger ja dass das
thema heute ich schreibe mit ihm jetzt
irgendwie seit klar ein paar wochen und
deswegen so die idee gekommen hey wieso
prank ich den ich einfach mal mit seinem
nexus one of the things prank jetzt hat
sich jetzt aber herausgestellt dass das
nicht irgendwie richtig geklappt hat
aber ich zeige euch erstmal will ich
angefangen habe als erstes lied habe ich
testament von sarah letsch gewählt hier
in ganz kurzer ausschnitt ok korrekt der
war richtig lang das ganze habe ich dann
am 15 oktober angefangen und zwar hatte
er mir dort eines partners geschickt
dann hab ich wieder spaß geschickt dann
eben alle geschickt und dann hab ich der
nächste sprachnachricht so ein bisschen
mal darüber geredet zu über mobbing und
irgendwie so weit dann hat er wieder mit
der sprachnachricht geantwortet und dann
habe ich halt gedacht okay jetzt fange
ich mal an so das lied so ein bisschen 1
leuten weil ich ja auch so ein bisschen
riehl machen wollte damit wäre
allerdings relativ schnell nach zwei
minuten aufgefallen
lokal dieses songtext ding was für die
diesmal ausgesucht hat also das wie
testament von sarah lesch das eignet
sich jetzt nicht so gut
dann habe ich anderes gewählt lassen
vielleicht habt ihr schon raus gehört
das ist das lied lass sie reden von
prinz pi was ich da gewählt habe und
darauf an er dann halt auch geantwortet
sorry bin beim friseur amerikaners lucas
klasse danke dass du so auf meine
nachrichten eingeht ich habe allerdings
nicht aufgegeben sondern noch mal etwas
geschrieben und darauf war lukas lang
geantwortet ja wo war ein bisschen
schade ihm alleine zu sitzen der pause
aber ich habe weitergemacht dem break
solche leute
darauf hat lukas lang geantwortet ja hh
damit deine antworten da könnte auch ein
buch schreiben hätte dann halt nur eine
halbe seite
ich habe weitergemacht mit dem frech und
weiter halt auch mit dem lied lasst die
reden von prinz pi und zwar nicht
angeschrieben und dann steht lukas mehr
als antwort 3 sprachnachrichten die
insgesamt drei minuten gehen kannst dich
irgendwie mal auf das beziehen was ich
dir schreibe in den sprachnachrichten
hat er irgendwas gesagt von wegen
was dass er alles machen kann bei seinem
bei seinem was er macht es halt wieder
nicht so richtig auf die nachrichten
leider eingegangen ich hatte gedacht
dass irgendwann so kommen der den kadi
zitiert gerade prinz pi oder so er hat
allerdings wirklich nicht rausgefunden
und dann haben wir die ganz einfach
weitergeschrieben und haben uns dann
aber auch über andere sachen unterhalten
und so und wie ich halt vorhin schon
gesagt habe das alles war am 5 oktober
und es liegt die ganze zeit nicht auf
meine sachen eingegangen hat es
überhaupt nicht gereicht ist ihnen
irgendwie versuche zu senken und dann
habe ich aber weiter gemacht am 18
oktober also zwei wochen später ihr seht
ihr mal wie lange dieser scheiß
praktisch oder der mache dies war mich
dann den schreck an tagen wie diesen von
fettes brot gewählt hier mal eine ganz
kurze einblendung nein ich habe da ganz
klassisch angefangen so wie jeder das
sieht auch kennt und zwar mit soja
benachrichtigung aus welcher mensch hat
seine whatsapp benachrichtigungen aus
lukas hawking er ist gerade in berlin
brauche was geht bei dir so dieses hotel
ist so dr
bis dahin wieder nicht gereicht
ok wenn jemand morgen wollen was geht
schreibt dann denkt man auch nicht ins
den anderen lied ich habe dann halt erst
die nachricht geschrieben alles bestens
stressig gerade mit uni sport und so
aber dann habe ich mich wieder auf den
songtext bezogen und der songtext geht
weiter mit ist klar benannt tagen wie
diesen von fettes brot des eingesetzten
ultra geiles lied was allgemein geiles
vid es aber anders einfach ein ultra
geiles lied für solche whatsapp rang
bringt wirklich einfach anwenden was
geht alles klar bei dir ich meine da
kommen kein mensch darauf dass das ganze
in whatsapp renk wird aber lukas
antwortet ja bei mir ist alles ganz gut
schreibe dir morgen bin grad zu müde um
zu schreiben
gleich sind schon seit zwei wochen daran
dich irgendwie bei whatsapp zu brenken
und dann schreibe ich dir abends und du
bist einfach kein mangel
auch kein bock mit dem haben darauf zu
schreiben deswegen habe ich dann am
nächsten mittag immer geschrieben wie
spät und er antwortet wieder mit zwei
sprachnachrichten die überhaupt nicht
mit dem thema zu tun hatten
dicker kuss ein spaß
ihr habt jetzt schon bemerkt ich habe
alleine diesen whatsapp rain schon zwei
wochen ich sag mal nicht arbeit gestellt
aber er gegenüber zwei wochen und ich
hatte jetzt auch schon die lieder
testament von sarah lesch prinz pi lass
sie reden und fettes brot oder tagen wie
diesen drinnen und deswegen habe ich mir
zeit ihr das ok kommen heute wo ich das
wieder eigentlich hochladen deswegen bin
ich jetzt marschiert das lied mit rein
welches lied passt bei einem lukas liga
prank besser als erlebt was von ihm
selber ist nämlich habe ich dann das
lied von ihm genommen alle welt
die korrekte leute allerdings habe ich
mir gedacht wenn ich ihm die lyrics
wirklich auf englisch schinke also auf
der originalsprache damit dass
wahrscheinlich direkt rollen dass ich
irgendwie seinen text irgendwie zieht
ihre deswegen hab ich das ganze zeit auf
deutsch übersetzen
englisch ist die cee lo green und seine
antwort war daraus
er hat noch immer nicht geantwortet ich
weiß nicht aber beim schläft aber
wahrscheinlich bekomme ich in drei
stunden eine antwort was so eine
dreiminütige sprachnachricht ist
überhaupt nicht das was ihr von dem
video meine damen und herren ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen der ostafrika jetzt
leider nicht so richtig geklappt
allerdings könnt ihr trotzdem in die
kommentare schreiben ob es das ganze
nochmal machen soll oder wie es euch
gefallen hat weil ich habe die
bewertungen für die nächsten sechs tage
noch aus einfach um die kommentare so
ein bisschen mehr den fokus darauf zu
legen dass mehr leute kommentare
schreiben übrigens könnt ihr mir auch
beim musical die folgen dort heiße ich
laser luca und habe derzeit eine eigene
challenge of musical i also ihr könnt
dort einfach ein video hochladen wo er
eine kettenreaktion macht und das
einfach unter dem hashtag kettenreaktion
posten
das ist glaube ich auch der musical die
startseite in der app oder so also ich
bekomme kein geld für nur ich hatte die
möglichkeit seinen channel zu machen und
das ist ganz cool check das mal aus und
sonst würde ich sagen sehen uns in einem
nächsten video wieder diese schießt in
letzter zeit jeder youtube-videos keine
ahnung warum